safety is top of mind as students
prepared to head back to class
especially in light of what happened at
the end of last school year in uvalde
texas well here in the valley metro is
training for all sorts of situations
including what to do in an active
assailant is on campus
thomas o'rourke elementary was packed
thursday morning not by students but
from law enforcement
metro and ccsd police working side by
side responding to an active assailant
exercise they say the department
normally slows down the momentum by
using de-escalation techniques but not
this time during an active assailant
situation
it is the responsibility of law
enforcement to have an aggressive
can respond in case of an emergency
officers facing real life situations
with simulated gunfire simulated
explosions and over 50 role players from
volunteers acting as teachers and
children this is not new to us after the
events of 2008 with the terrorist
attacks in mumbai the leadership for las
vegas metropolitan police department
created a section to proactively train
all of our officers makes me feel a lot
better sending them to school trista ben
is a mother of two and says
conversations about shootings with her
kids are never easy but are necessary
with her mostly because he's just
starting school but
i've told her
to not be panicky
as much as she can and listen to the
older adults